hi i'm katya and i'm trixie and we are
going to read some
thirst tweets today that's how long
people have been in quarantine
they're thirst tweeting us
first one's for both of us trixie and
katya own this ass i like that the
grammar
is working and i think owning property
is really important it's one of the
smartest things you can do with your
money i have several international
investors in my ass
right this one's for me trixie mattel
let me sniff sniff your thighs
please i'll snip your thighs that's it
sniff my thighs
i think this is what we call a burner
account get close to a drag queen you'll
realize
sniffing is not something you want to be
in but a cloud
of pink sugar perfume barely just being
literally the smell of an old rubber
band yeah that's very generous
um okay this one's for me when my best
friend introduced drag race to me seeing
katie zemo awoke something in me
my dick oh it says my dick i didn't see
that
i thought you added that
just saw a video of katy and turksy
kissing and now i'm horny
oh i am in a bad mood now what happened
to you people
i'd let trixie mattel break down my back
door in or out of drag
oh is that it the back door being there
but he has his astrological sign
in the name on twitter that's a bit of a
red flag to me but you know what based
on the picture
i guess i would i am a bottom but how
does the bottom break down the back door
i i was like compost in the backyard a
little bit
watch i'm gonna go to his house and kick
the [ __ ] out of his actual back door and
go
you said yes also that's really gross
listen
anal fishers are having a thing right
now you need people no we need to be not
breaking down back doors
i want my back blown out no you don't
you really don't you don't want to go to
the doctor after sex
i'm all bottom for about six minutes
yeah and then i'm back to being nothing
i'm back to being and not even social
you know sometimes
it'll take a long time to come yeah i
could never make it work
i'd be like you got five minutes because
i want my [ __ ] to be like super
sweet like someone running through there
with a cart like
you got 30 seconds i'm gonna like get
the clue run to the bread aisle like
i'm not trying to like slow splash and
grab with a time limit this isn't
a lazy sunday at galson's this is
legends of the hidden temple yeah
high thoughts i want to be a cigarette
so katy can smoke me and touch me with
her fingers
people who are attracted to
crossdressers i think often are really
into smoking yeah
cross dressers i've done it i've done it
yeah they want to watch you smoke yeah
they love it they loved it do you think
it's like the red lip and like the
exhale what is it
who's this you were doing that oh
[Music]
you want to know what i want a trixia
kiss we haven't had one in so
long it doesn't even have to be a kiss i
just want a trixia moment of interaction
does anyone have a one-hour compilation
of tricks in yourself i need to come
now i need to what these are all
trolling
i need to come down now i wish my own
boyfriend felt half as passionate about
me sexually
as any of these teen girls kante's moan
and ding dong made me obnoxiously erect
and i don't have it
you know what i was watching an episode
of the real housewives and erica james
was driving a fast
car and she was going to make a card
yeah so i think you can have a hard
yeah absolutely i think it's a
figurative hardness when i'm that my
most turned on
there's no no no this
is like very soft knotted is knotted up
okay i want both trixie and katya to top
me
and then a female emoji like this he
wants us to top him
and he's going i don't know what's wrong
with me am i busty with the rake mom i'm
gonna make this real easy
no is it wrong for me to want trixie and
katya to fill my ass
in drag no they want to be in dragon us
fill their ass fill my ass with what
pennies
finger me like you're manually rewinding
a vhs tape isn't that like
this and then turning yeah you want to
be churned like butter for like a long
time
all these [ __ ] are going to clip these
of us responding to their tweets
and then just and then actually jerk off
to them yeah let people have if people
are watching us to jerk off
weapons plus is only five dollars a
month yeah that's cheaper than porn
might look around and have katya bust
this antique [ __ ]
okay so oh boy [ __ ]
also what's an antique [ __ ] 25 i hate
bussy
i hate it so much it's so weird
just say my ass killed my ass
burn my ass ass is the easiest word it's
only one syllable although don't talk
dirty to me in general because i have a
very like
pragmatic response to like so you'll get
like yeah
suck my dick i'm like i am
tell me what you want next yeah don't
narrate damages
after well thank you for thirst tweeting
us i think we learned a lot and honestly
it kind of was empowering for me because
this was everything i thought it was
gonna be
hey smeagle you still have that ring
yeah i'd love to have you wrap your
smeagle foreskin around my
pointy head i want better for you guys
aim for the sky
yeah right now you're aiming for yeah
this is the garage
get the supermodels get the hip hop
stars get them get all the hot people
people who really deserve it we're just
too busy and uh you can catch new
episodes of our show
on the wow presents plus app
uh